I don't feel like leaving the house today,
but unless I have to
how the fuck am I supposed to get out of this driveway?
Always hot and it's so hot
I'm in a bush
in another bush.
I don't normally park in this driveway and that is why.
Okay, let's go.
One thing about me that you probably should know
is that I am actually an emo.
My Spotify rep last year told me so
and I'm not surprised because
this is the sort of shit that I love to listen to.
I have no idea why,
but the traffic was so heavy
and I kept having all these intrusive thoughts
like I was gonna get into an accident or something
but I was fine obviously.
But does that happen to anyone else or just me?
Okay, help me pick a dress
option No. 1 option No. 2. I cannot zip up.
This one's quite cute,
but if I lean over
getting more than you pack it for.
I don't know. I just feel like it's a no immediately. No,
I don't know.
I'm not having very much luck.
It's just bloody a lot of fabric.
I can't I can't do it up.
I can't do anything up by myself.
It's kind of fire though.
Could be quite cute to go like dark theme. Yeah,
the amount of partners
I've heard coming in to pick dresses up for this
significant other.
Oh my God, I can't
I love love Also,
I'm not having fun doing this.
I don't like doing this last one.
I am struggling.
Cute dresser.
My God, I was in that shop for like an hour
and I wish I was joking.
I think I tried on pretty much every dress,
but I just feel like
I don't know if I like suits,
anything. Anyway,
we found a dress.
I don't really like shopping.
I don't find it that enjoyable.
I don't like trying things on
and I just tried on so many things. Anyway,
thank you for hanging out with me.
You made it so much more enjoyable.
I'm gonna go home.
I'm gonna decompress for a little bit
and then the kids are gonna be home
not long after I get back.
So I'm gonna leave it here. But, uh,
we'll see you again very soon.